you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
boris johnson and joe biden meet ahead
of the g7 summit tomorrow with
climate change a key part of the agenda
after a washout may some areas could see
a heat wave this weekend
we find out if climate change is to
blame for our weather getting stuck
[Music]
and the carbon footprint of a cornish
pasty
is revealed
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show
where we track the changes happening to
our world right now
and meet those developing the solutions
well as world leaders from the g7
countries prepare to meet this weekend
in cornwall
it's expected that the climate crisis
will be a
key area of discussion and ahead of the
official summit which begins tomorrow
boris johnson and the u.s
president joe biden have held talks on
key issues
including the environment well in a
moment we'll hear from
mary robinson chair of the elders on
what might be achieved at this weekend's
meeting
but first sky's dan whitehead has the
latest
there is no doubt that climate change is
right at the top of the agenda here at
the g7 summit the u.s president joe
biden
and uk prime minister boris johnson
holding those early bilateral
meetings today to try and really set the
agenda
over the weekend that all seven leaders
can come to some agreement agreements
when it comes
to the challenges that climate change
presents
and there will be pressure from no less
than 40
groups who are holding events right
across cornwall the likes of ocean
rebellion extinction rebellion
who want to let the leaders know um
about the challenges that the world is
facing
from oil from climate change sea level
rises
i mean simply driving in here to send
ives this afternoon
there are at least half a dozen or so
bridges over the main roads with
extinction rebellion
banners and protesters waving at every
tv crew
so they want that message to get out
there and they'll be making their voices
heard and of course what better
backdrop for the leaders and for the
protesters to get their message across
here in cornwall of course so marine
county
so much marine history here and of
course they are impacted
on a daily basis by some of the
challenges that climate change presents
so we will see those protests over the
weekend and undoubtedly climate change
itself
will be right at the top of the agenda
for the g7 leaders well one person who
knows the inner workings of these
high-level talks better than most
is mary robinson the former president of
ireland is now
chair of the elders the international
organization of global leaders
i spoke to her earlier and i started by
asking what she thought about the cuts
to the uk's foreign aid budget
to put into legislation zero percent
point seven percent
was real leadership and frankly it's
never been needed more
this is the wrong time and the wrong way
especially when you have presidency of
the cop
we need to build trust with developing
countries the hundred billion dollars a
year
um of climate finance half of it going
to adaptation
has been long promised and we still
haven't got there
and meanwhile developing countries are
seeing the huge
solidarity packages that the richer
parts of the world
you know understandably want for their
citizens and are able to do
for their citizens but you know the
contrast between not able to reach the
100 billion it's becoming
an angry point and when you know the the
the presidency of cop has decided
in this year of all years to reduce what
was
leadership and that means cutting
budgets
in yemen cutting budgets in sudan
cutting budgets in syria
you know it's shocking the presidency of
the cop has to have the trust
of developing countries if we're going
to have a successful cop
that's just the absolutely prerequisite
what you're touching on there is that it
needs to go deeper doesn't it than uh
sort of cheerful communique at the end
of the g7 there needs to be a lot of
detail
what detail specifically would you like
to see
i want to see the g7 commit
to every country this year
in glasgow having a nationally
determined contribution which is real
worked out measurable and about
being aligned to the 1.5 degrees so it's
yeah yes it's good to have the long-term
goal of being zero carbon and zero
emissions by uh 2050 um but
we're more interested in what's going to
happen in 2025 2024
2026 you know measurable just as the
vaccines have to be measurable which is
why
the elders really support the gavi
um kovacs uh commitment that was made
for a billion by the first of september
and 2 billion by mid 20
20 22 not saying in a global way we will
vaccinate the whole world
that's kind of rhetoric we need
precision well you can see more of my
interview with mary robinson on our
youtube channel you just head to
youtube.com
sky news well we can take a look now at
some of the day's other climate news
and the prince of wales has hosted a
meeting with ceos from some of the
world's leading companies
ahead of a meeting with g7 leaders he
was joined by the u.s climate envoy john
kerry
and alex sharma the president of cop 26.
well tomorrow the chief executives will
meet the g7 leaders the first
such meeting between government and
global business leaders
to discuss the acceleration of
sustainable investment
and the first collaboration between the
biodiversity and climate bodies of the
un
has said that narrowly focused actions
to combat climate change
can harm nature and vice versa they say
any measures that focus too narrowly on
combating climate change
should be evaluated in terms of their
overall benefits
and risks for example generating
renewable energy can cause
surges of mining activity or use
large areas of land
the seabed off the coast of sussex is
going to be leased from the queen
as part of plans to create a marine park
the water was previously home to a vast
historic
kelp forest and was a haven for marine
life
but 90 of it has been lost over recent
decades
there are also plans to expand the park
along the entire coastline of east
and west sussex
and the coral reef ecosystems could
dissolve
faster than they grow by 2050 that's
according
to a new study reefs have to regenerate
and grow
to survive depositing calcium carbonate
to make
new structures a process called
calcification
calcification rates have declined by
about four percent a year since the 70s
researchers believe the drop is partly
due to ocean
warming and coral bleaching
and a cave painting thought to be the
oldest in the world
is rapidly peeling off due to climate
change
the 44 000 year old artwork on
indonesia's island of
sulawesi is being exfoliated off due to
increasing salt erosion in the cave
scientists say that warming temperatures
alongside prolonged drought combined
with heavy monsoonal rainfall
has created conditions intensifying the
salt crystallization
now temperatures across the uk have been
steadily
rising this week some areas could even
experience a heat wave
this weekend but the warmer weather that
we've been experiencing
is rather different isn't it to last
month which was dominated by low
pressure heavy downpours and
prolonged spells of rain so what
is going on with our weather we're here
to explain more
is kirsty mccabe from the royal
meteorological society also
sky's weather presenter afternoon to you
kirsty and just explain
why is our weather getting stuck and has
it got anything to do with
climate change hello there sam
lots to talk about when it comes to the
weather and weather patterns
and it does seem like maybe we have been
stuck in something of a cool wet me
and then quite a nice warm june and it
is all to do with the jet stream
and now the jet stream is this
fast-moving ribbon of air that's high up
in our atmosphere and it steers low
pressure systems around on the ground
and it's all to do with the temperature
difference between the poles and the
equator
and when there's a large temperature
contrast like we get in the winter then
that means a stronger jet stream and we
see low pressure systems move across the
uk
in summer the contrast is weaker and
that allows the jet stream to move
further north
and we get more settled weather so in
may there the jet stream was a little
bit further south and that's why we got
all that
wet weather when it comes to the links
with climate change it's a little bit
inconclusive at the moment um some
school of thought is that the jet stream
will weaken
because there's not so much of a
temperature difference if the arctic is
warming and it is warming much more
quickly than the rest of the globe then
due to something called the arctic
amplification
then that will reduce the temperature
contrast the jet stream won't be as
strong
however there is also an argument that
with a
warmer world a warmer globe we're going
to see tropical storms moving a little
bit further north into northern
latitudes
and they will interact and strengthen
the jet stream so at the moment
we can't really pin it down to climate
change but when it comes to heat waves
we can now heat waves are pretty much
likely to be linked to climate change
we're going to see more intense and more
frequent heatwaves
with just a small increase in global
temperature it has a big
impact good to see you in your glorious
garden there thank you kirsty thank you
now with the leaders of the world's
seven richest countries meeting in
cornwall tomorrow to discuss the
defining issues of our time
there is one question that remains
unanswered and that is
what is the carbon footprint of a
cornish pasty
well luckily for us a team at the
university of
exeter have been doing the sums and
professor stefan
joins me now to fill us in on their
findings
professor boehm good to talk to you why
are some of the country's finest minds
turning their attention to the humble
cornish pasty
well it's a very popular product 120
million of these are produced each year
here in cold war
and i'm calling uh talking to you from
from cornwall from the penryn campus
and we've teamed up with capacity makers
to
first of all assess what is actually the
carbon footprint of
each uh pasty and we found about 1.5 to
2 kilos per pasty which actually is not
too bad if you compared to
other full meals like a roast dinner
or a lasagna so it's not a bad
carbon footprint but of course it can
still be lowered
particularly if you're thinking about
120 million
times these um it's it's significant
so what are the main drivers of that
carbon footprint
well if you open up a pasty i bought
this early on our campus shop
so you have about um
a whole range of ingredients but a
typical cornish pasty has
passed meat in there beef
um a range of vegetables and of course
the pastries made from
wheat all of that has a carbon footprint
so we've used something called
life cycle analysis to estimate what
the carbon footprint is of all of all of
these ingredients
and of course meat is you know is the
biggest contributor here
uh beef has quite a large carbon
footprint so if you um
take away the meat or you source the
meat differently
you're reared in different ways you have
organic better aquaculture
then you can lower the carbon footprint
quite significantly so we developed a
tool
that allows capacity makers to assess
that
carbon footprint and alter the
ingredients
change the composition of opacity to to
lower the carbon footprint
well i'm sure the world is definitely a
better place for it uh professor
stefan bowen good to talk to you thank
you thanks very much
well that is everything from us for
today but coming up tomorrow we've got a
special extended program
live from cornwall as that g7 summit
gets underway
well you can see that here on sky news
at half past six tomorrow evening
hope to see you then